the auto giant General Motors is
entering a new business often described
as air B&B for cars starting this week
many people who owned or leased newer
models from GM's brands can sign up to
rent out their vehicles and the program
is called pure cars it's part of GM's
established car sharing at maven pier
cars launched initially in Chicago
Detroit
Ian Arbor and Michigan GM says it will
be available in more cities this fall
Lea Gallagher is fortunes magazine
senior editor at large and one of our
favorites Leigh welcome to the table
thanks for having me so this is
interesting right this is very sharing
you know how how is GM want to carry
this out very so this is you know Jim is
doing a lot with car sharing and has
ever since it launched this platform
called maven a few years ago if you're
an uber driver you can get a car from
maven and use it for you it's called
maven gig they have all sorts of things
going on this is the first time a big
automaker has gotten into this
peer-to-peer car rental service this is
you described it as an Airbnb for cars
it is regular people renting out their
cars to other regular people and so it's
very disruptive in that way there are a
few startups that already do this
company's called get around and Turo but
this is a big deal for GM coming into
this slice of the market and
legitimizing it so anybody with a GM car
can sign up there must be some kind of
there are some rules it has to be a
model that's - 2015 or more you have to
be vetted if you do it actually someone
will come and inspect your car and
outfit it with decals and put the
technology in it that will allow it
really is it relies on a technology that
lets the the renter access your car you
don't ever have to see each other so is
the idea if I have a GM car and let's
say it costs $5 a month yeah right my um
my program to own it as 500 a month I
could the days that I'm out of town or
on vacation I could lease it out and try
and recoup some money that helps pay my
months exactly and not only that but
let's say you live in New York City and
you commute by public trip
I'm een the theory is most people it's
an asset that most people have that sits
idle oh wow all right so it's monetizing
that the same way with Airbnb you're
monetizing your your home so yeah is
this is basically just a new financing
mechanism for GM in other words they
want to get more people who will now buy
a car because it's not gonna cost so
much because of what Norah just outlined
yes and they want if you're monetizing
the car that's sitting in your driveway
maybe yeol after a while trade up or buy
a second car you know there is there is
that but this is also a part of you know
this is really the Wild West of car
ownership and car and getting around
right now between autonomous cars and
ride-hailing and and then car sharing
and so but this company is getting into
it rather than sort of fighting it well
is that Wild West makes me think of a
place where there aren't a lot of rules
and people got hurt so what's the swing
look I mean this is brand-new this
peer-to-peer carbon so and look at
Airbnb went through a lot of challenges
a lot of stuff happened on that platform
because you're opening up private
products for public consumption and so
so what happens if I rent your car you
rent my car and then I have an accident
in your car well Jim will hover turn
your car thanks a lot sorry right I mean
I can't says it will cover a million
dollars there's a million dollar policy
for that car while it's being used
during that reservation but you know the
question is will your own car insurance
policy
what's because this is commercial use of
a private car that was you know probably
not intended that way and it's so it is
brave new world but this whole sharing
economy this is a brave new world and
how much how much does it cost it caught
it depends but the owners set the price
and you know the one thing that data can
do is you can have analytics that tells
you what the going rate is in your
market depending on the time when the
owner says the price and the owner gets
60 percent the car company gets 40 yes
so there's something in it for everybody
okay and GM also rents car it seems like
it would hurt the car rental that is
that is the one entity that will
probably you know fight back against
this although GM buys sells cars to
rental company it's just it's everyone's
partnering with everyone it's very
confusing the Gallagher always like to
see you as one of our favorite people
thank you good - thanks